- the Finland station Edmund Wilson's
1940 study of revolutionary politics and
ideas was recently reprinted in
paperback next on book TV pulitzer
prize-winning historian Louis Menand who
wrote the introduction to the new
edition comments on the work and its
impact this talk from politics and prose
bookstore in Washington DC is one hour
now let's come to the topic for the
evening this evening brings together
three of my favorite things my first is
the this is not in any particular order
except that I want to end with the
speaker the the first is the New York
Review of Books Publishing program we
have a display in the front of the store
of the books that they've been
republishing and they're doing such a
marvelous job of bringing back into
print wonderful books that have long
been out of print and many of them are
so terrific and they some of them I
haven't read before some of them I have
read before and um it it could keep you
going I mean any book group that wants
to just adopt New York review books
would be they would be the most
stimulating situation so I want you to
take a look at the at the books in front
and and I want you to take a look at the
catalogue to which I have here in my
hand and if we don't have something that
you think we should have you should let
me know I particularly want to mention a
month in the country by JH car which was
a book that was that I had kind of heard
of but um when it was brought back in
print by Newark Review of Books I was
just knocked out by it
it's about a first world war veteran and
I also want to mention the go-between
by Hartley which I read about 20 no more
than 25 years ago many years ago and
founded a stunning book tonight we are
celebrating the hundredth book that the
New York Review is publishing in their
wonderful publishing program amazingly
um Edmund Wilson's books are mostly out
of print we do have copies of patriotic
gore which we've been selling her in the
store but we have thanks to the New York
Review to the Finland station which was
surely a formative book for many people
in my generation it has been brought
back to print others really
I don't can't think of another person
who impressed me more when I was a
youngster and continues to impress me
with his ability to bring history and
literature together and I've always
loved Edmund Wilson and I hope that he
is being reintroduced to new generations
I know my when my son was in college he
said mom if it weren't for you I never
would have known about Edmund Wilson
they never mentioned him
so this is a real problem and that
brings me to the third wonderful reason
for being here this evening and that's
Louie Manon it's just a privilege to
have him back here he came here for the
metaphysical Club and I know that many
of you are here because you enjoyed that
book so much
it was speaking of combining history and
literature and biography it was a
marvelous book and we enjoyed his essays
in the fall and he was nice enough to
come down tonight to reintroduce Edmund
Wilson's to the Finland station
[Applause]
thank you very much it's great to be
here I just got here because I took a
high-speed train so I was 45 minutes
late so I'm a little rushed but it's
very nice to come back to the bookstore
and talk a little bit about this volume
that the New York Review Books has
brought out they called me about six
months ago to ask if I would be
interested in writing the introduction
to this book to the filling station
reprint and I said yes immediately
because it had been a big influence on
me and I think when I was writing my
book the metaphysical Club this was the
book Wilson's was the book that I had in
my head the whole way going through I
first read it when I was about 21 or 22
back in the 1970s when it had been
brought out in the second edition by
Farah Straus and Giroux and when I was
writing my book I never looked at it
again because I felt that I had an
impression in my head about how the book
worked and what it was about the book
that I wanted to emulate but I didn't
really want to cheat by looking to see
what Wilson actually did in the book so
I really kind of religiously stayed away
from it a book that I and when I was
writing my book I hadn't read for 15 or
20 years so the second reason I said yes
to the New York Review people when they
asked me to write the introduction was I
was kind of curious to see what it was
like to read it now almost 30 years
later and it still retained a lot of its
wonderful qualities to me and it was a
pleasure to try to write about what
those qualities were and what I think
really good history writing is to the
finless station was first published in
1940 September 1940 and as you know the
book is a history of essentially the
intellectual origins of the Russian
Revolution and it culminates with
Lenin's arrival at the Finland station
which kind of inaugurates the Bolshevik
phase of the Russian Revolution
September 1940 was about the worst time
in his
of the world to write a book about the
intellectual origins of the Russian
Revolution because about a month before
the book came out Leon Trotsky who's a
major character in the book was murdered
by an assassin with an ice axe a
Stalinist agent in Mexico City and of
course a year before the book came out
in August 1939 the Soviet Union had
signed a non-aggression pact with Nazi
Germany this brought an end to the
Popular Front a phase in which the
Communist Party attempted to getting
league with other progressive
organizations those progressive
organizations quickly dropped their
association with the Communist Party and
so in 1940 Soviet Union and Nazi Germany
were still allies the Germans had not
yet invaded Russia so it was really not
a period in which most American readers
were feeling particularly sympathetic
towards Soviet Union or Lenin or the
Russian Revolution now a the interesting
thing about this is the Wilson was
perfectly aware of what had happened by
the time the book came out he began
writing the book in the early 1930s he
tells a story about walking down a
street in New York City in the East 50s
and just coming up with the idea for
this book and this would been probably
1933 or 1934 Wilson was at this stage of
his career he had written his probably
most widely read work of literary
criticism axels Castle had come out of
1931 at this stage of his career who's
very interested in politics and his
politics were quite left-wing in 1932 he
had voted for the communist candidate
for president of the United States and a
year later he had signed a manifesto
advocating a dictatorship of the
proletariat in the United States
Wilson thought as many other people
thought that the Great Depression the
crash and the Great Depression were
proof that capitalism had failed and
they took that as a turning point in
history and that something else would
have to replace capitalist order and for
Wilson as for many of his friends among
intellectuals and writers and many other
American socialism was the alternative
either communism or some other form of
socialist
politics and economics so when Wilson
started the book he had this idea of
telling the history of Marxist thought
and socialist thought going all the way
back to the French Revolution and that's
what to the Finland station is of course
while he was writing the book
he took him a long time to do it one
reason for that is that he had to learn
both German and Russian in order to
write the book two languages he did not
know and that many people afterwards say
he still didn't know even after he
finished writing the book most famous of
course Vladimir Nabokov who of course
was brilliant brilliantly fluent in
Russian one of his original languages in
Wilson we used to correct his Russian
all the time
so that took a long time and then Wilson
also traveled to Russia 1935 while he
was working on the book in order to to
see the country and to see where Lenin
and Trotsky had been born and so forth
and he wrote a diary of the trip which
he published when he got back along with
some travel writings of travel in the
United States and the title of that book
as travels in two democracies so you can
get an idea of what Wilson thought of
the Soviet Union in 1935 he he wanted to
believe that it was a true democracy but
by 1936 in 1937 at the time of the trial
Moscow trials it was quite clear to
Wilson that this was not the case that
it was a totalitarian regime and that
Stalin was a cruel dictator and he
confessed this in letters to his friends
he argued with many people who were
still fellow travelers or communist
party members against Stalin and against
the Soviet Union so when the book came
out he writes a letter to one of his
friends Louise bogan and he says to her
I'm finishing up to the Finland station
just as the Soviet Union is about 2nx
Finland so he felt rather despairing
about it and with good reason because
the book did quite poorly when it first
came out published in 1940 by 1947 and
it sold 4,500 copies the book was then
reprinted in 1953 by as an anchor
paperback and you remember anchor was
one of the original paperback lines and
one of the things Jason Epstein did who
was the founder of anchor books was to
bring back all this Wilson that and
publish it in paperback that
gone out of print did a huge amount
towards renovating Wilson's career in
the 1950s and 60s
so did pretty well as an actor paperback
but it really did much better in the
1960s for obvious reasons was a lot more
interest in left-wing thought and
Marxism in particular in that in 1972
which is the last year of Wilson's life
are Strauss as I said brought out the
second edition for that for that edition
Wilson wrote an introduction which is
reprinted in the New York Review reprint
an introduction in which he explained
the mistakes that he had made in the
book in particular his portrayal of
Lenin as a very humane person he was not
as explicit as he was elsewhere and his
writings about some of the things that
Lenin did which were which were evidence
of his own totalitarian system he
introduced concentration camps into
Russia
he used terror as a system of control he
had show trials he did all the things
that Stalin did and he was just as
ruthless as Stalin but Wilson did say
that he had drawn his portrait of Lenin
from unreliable sources and that
accounted for it still when you read the
book you can tell Lenin is the hero of
the book and the reason is book is a
series of stories about people who have
an idea about revolutionary change
overthrowing capitalism replacing it
with a workers state and this idea as it
develops by these very lonely thinkers
throughout the 19th century with feeling
feeling very little hope of ever
bringing us about finds its
personification in the figure of
Vladimir Lenin and Lenin then becomes
the ideal type of the intellectual as a
man of action he's the one who
understands the whole philosophical
background and the whole political
history of the movement that he leads
and he's also totally effective as a
leader of a political party and of a
nation and therefore he sums up this
whole history that Wilson has laid out
for us so the narrative is a triumphal
narrative it to the Fenland station and
the problem with it of course is that
now when we look back at the history of
socialism it's really a narrative of
failure it's a narrative of that ideal
betrayed in many ways and Wilson
couldn't get that into his book he'd
ridden it sort of at the wrong time sure
if he'd written it later he would have
gotten the story much closer to the way
we think about it in a way it's
interesting because the way that the
book is set up is that the idea that the
French Revolutions ideals about equality
and the rights of man were betrayed by
Napoleon and then the revolutions in
Europe of 1848 which very much
influenced Marx and his generation also
failed and created a series of reactions
in Europe so the way to end it would
really would have been to draw in the
Peck draw the parallel between Leonard
and Napoleon to say that Lenin too had
betrayed the socialist tradition that he
claimed to be the champion of but as I
say will by the time Wilson got to the
end of the book and I know from writing
a book that takes a long time you you
just feel like I'm just going to stop
right thought it was kind of stopped I'm
not going to try to bring this any
farther and I think he felt he had to
stop when he did Wilson didn't realize
right away but he but he did quickly
enough that the title that had coming
into his mind when he was walking down
the street in the early 1930s and this
idea of writing a book about the history
of socialism came to him that the title
was taken from the title of a novel to
the to the filling station is drawn from
Virginia Woolf's novel to the lighthouse
and it's not really an accident as we
used to say in the old Soviet Union
because there's something that's very
novelistic about to the fiddling station
I want to talk about that for a few
minutes because it's I think the quality
of the book that infected my own
thinking so much and that I still think
is so wonderfully pulled off by Wilson
in it when you write history and one of
the things that you very quickly learn
it seems obvious but but encountering it
in realities can be quite quite stunning
is how cut off you are from the past and
how and how much of the past almost all
of it is available only in printed
documents really when we think about
what historians do they look at print
and I remember writing my book I was a
little shocked by this I don't know why
I should have been shocked by it but I
was a little shocked to find that
everything that I knew about the past
was mediated because it was had been
translated into some printed form
and of course one of the other things
you realize is that a lot of the stuff
is just lost so there's the stuff that
never made it into print which you
really it's almost impossible to know
about there's the stuff that made it
into print and there's the stuff that
made it into print and got destroyed or
lost or somehow disappeared from the
scene so you're dealing with very
fragmentary bits of evidence so the one
feeling you have as an historian is how
how isolated you are from the reality
that you're trying to bring to life and
trying to understand on the other hand
this is the this is the really annoying
part of it
there's also too much information in a
way because because there's a lot of
fragmentary information out there about
the past you're never really sure which
is the relevant information if you look
at biographies for example of historical
figures you find particularly ones
who've been written about several times
people always use the same letters the
same diary entries the same passages
from books and so forth the same
anecdotes because they're constructing a
very similar profile of this figure but
if you go dig around you can always find
other evidence that either contradicts
the profile that people have taken as
conventional about that figure or that
suggests a completely different
narrative there's a huge amount of
speculation that goes on in trying to
reconstruct a personality Emelia a
moment in history one of the great
things I think about to the Finland
stations it manages to evoke a lost time
it manages to evoke what it felt like in
the 19th century to think the way the
marks and angles and their precursors
Misha lay and by both and Fourier and
Stan seem all the way they thought I
think part of the reason Wilson is
successful is because he shared with
them a certain belief those figures he
was writing about and that was the
belief that there's a meaning in history
the belief that history has a plot and
that the roles that we play in our
individual lives although they may seem
to us to be an effectual it may seem as
though we're failures and trying to
realize our visions of how to make the
world a better place in the great scheme
of things those ideas will unfold
and the are our wishes for life will be
realized not by us maybe not by the next
generation maybe but somewhere down the
road so the history of socialist thought
for wilson's the history of exactly that
is the history of these isolated
thinkers and I'll read a couple passages
in a minute from the book to give you an
idea of how he creates these figures
these isolated figures sitting in these
under furnished apartments being kicked
out by the rent collectors not having
food to eat
nobody reading their books still worked
on this idea about the future of
civilization in the confidence that
history someday would realize that idea
and that they were playing their part in
that
I think Wilson felt that very much when
he started the book he had the same
belief in history that's how I was able
to recreate it now in saying this about
how history is written I think for my
for myself when I was trying to figure
out how to write a history that was
similarly sort of broad in scope my book
goes from the middle of the nineteenth
century to about 1919 as a lot of
characters very much like Wilson's does
is that on the one hand historical
research is an empirical enterprises
we're looking for facts we're not
looking to make things up we're trying
to be very scrupulous about finding
material that we can verify as valid and
feel confident in the use that we're
making of it that it's not taken out of
context or contradicted by other
material that we should be taking notice
of the other hand historical writing is
a work of imagination it is like writing
a novel in the sense that it doesn't
really matter what the facts say if you
can't put them into motion for people
it's sort of like you've done the
analogy of movies movies are single
photographs which are run by the eye at
a certain speed to give the illusion of
motion so the same thing is true of the
facts in a work of history it's not the
facts themselves it's getting the facts
running by at the correct speed so that
the reader has the illusion of time
passing and things really happening
that's what brings things to
life in a work of history now why is
that important well we could say well
it's important because it gives pleasure
to the reader right it's more fun to
read a history that has characters like
characters in a novel and seems to have
a plot that's unfolding and creates a
sense of suspense but it's more than
that it's that in order to understand
the facts correctly you first actually
have to get the feel of what it was like
to live in that time
that's what Wilson tries to do he tries
to show us what it was like to be a
thinker in the 19th century and once we
know that did it make sense of the
biographical and political facts because
we can get inside the world that those
people were in it's a gift of intuition
that he had he had it as a literary
critic some of his famous portraits of
writers and you can see it here
animating this whole history so I'm
going to read a couple passages because
it's silly for me just to talk when we
have Wilson's example for you of a
couple of the characters that he tries
to create in the book and then I'm happy
to talk some more about Wilson or or
history of Marxism whatever you like the
first of these is jules mitchell a the
french historian
Misha lay is the first character in the
book and he was an historian of France
beginning with the French Revolution
then going back all the way to the
beginning of France and a marvelous
writer and he's the first figure in the
book because the book is about Wilson
says it's about the writing and acting
of history it's about people who write
history and then people like Lenin and
Trotsky who act history so Mitchell is a
great writer of history and he begins
the book I think because Wilson thinks
Mitchell a is important because he's the
first historian to grasp that the French
Revolution brought Europe into modern
times he's really writing about the
transition from an aristocratic and
feudal system into the modern world the
transition that the French Revolution
marks this is just a passage from the
chapter on Mitchell a and I read it to
you because I think Wilson is very much
reflecting on his own practice here he's
in other words he's sort of in described
would be chalets doing
in the very early pages of his book he's
giving us an idea of the kind of book
that he's written and how to read it and
intervals Misha lay halts his narrative
to give a description of the general
life of the time the habits the costumes
the moral atmosphere and here he
displays his peculiar genius for
identifying himself with each period as
he passes through it this is one of the
main differences between Misha leis
method in the method of the ordinary
historian the ordinary historian knows
what is going to happen in the course of
his historical narrative because he
knows what has really happened but
Mitchell a is able to put us back in
upper stages of the stream of time so
that we grope with the people of the
past themselves share their heroic
faiths are dismayed by their unexpected
catastrophe Fields feel for all our
knowledge of after the event that we do
not know precisely what is coming
Mitchell a responds with the sensitivity
of a poet to every change of tempo
movement or scope he develops an
infinitely varied technique to register
different phases the genius which has
been admired in his books on Natural
History and which enabled him to render
the humming Berg's darting the flap of
the frigate bird the lightness and song
of the Lark the muffled swoop of the owl
with an accuracy almost tenha Sounion
appears in his treatment of history in
much more extraordinary ways the
processes which lead up to the
revolution are presented in a rotating
series of episodes we made to see how
things are going without very much
comment by Misha lay as we observe
certain tendencies recurring and growing
gradually more pronounced in the
behavior of various individuals or
groups I do not know of anything in
literature more remarkable in its way
than the skill with which Misha lay
leads us as we follow generation after
generation of kings to feel the old
virtue passing out of them the lapsing
of their contact with the people the
great rooms of Fontainebleau and
Versailles seem to get colder and larger
and the figures smaller and more alone
they are not usually made odious so much
as wretched Misha lay remembered the
poor queer relics of the sanitarium in
which he had lived and we are finally
startled but not surprised to find Louie
the Sun King himself eclipsed in his
windowless inside room bored with the
old and deaf med
and Demento nagged by the quarrels of
the monks and losing his magnificent
manners at last in his fury against the
obstinate parliament to give us a final
symbol for the monarchy misha lay is
only to describe without comment the
expense and the clumsy complication of
the great waterworks at Marley which
make the Versailles fountains play which
fill the air for miles around with her
agonized creakings
and groanings of course the major figure
in the book is Karl Marx and I think
when I read the book that was the most
exciting part of it for me
Wilson was clearly heavily influenced by
Marx when he wrote the book I think he
very much shared Marx's view of economic
history I'm not sure there are other
areas of Marx Marx's work he
particularly agreed with and it's
interesting his treatment of Marx's
ideas on the one hand his capital is
sorry his chapter on capital does
capital I think is a very brilliant
analysis and summation of that book
it's it shows great understanding of
Marx's economics in particular the
weakness of Marx's theory the labor
theory of value
Wilson is very keen on pinpointing that
but great sympathy with what Marx was
doing which was attempting to anatomize
a social condition that was extremely
difficult to understand intellectually
but which was very powerfully
provocative on a personal level the
sufferings of workers under industrial
capitalism and Wilson very much admired
this enormous amount of labour that Marx
put into that analysis although it was
incomplete and no doubt flawed in many
ways the other hand Marx had no sympathy
for dialectical materialism he has a
whole chapter called the myth of the
dialectic and and almost everything he
wrote about Marx and Engels he makes fun
of the dialectic this is annoying
because Wilson had no idea what the
dialectic was he had no understanding of
it at all and he gives a very brief
account of what he calls Hegel's
dialectic which is actually not Hegel's
dialectic um so he spends a great deal
of time making fun of marx and engels
for this and it's a little exasperated
to the reader because it's not
particularly fair and it's
so I think shows a weakness on Wilson's
own part which is that he wasn't very
dialectical as a thinker he didn't think
in a particularly philosophical way or
even theoretical way about most of what
he was writing about is rather literal
straightforward common sense kind of guy
who was a journalist and he and he any
thought with the virtues and the vices
of a journalist but he was very
sympathetic to Marx's character I think
partly because he by this by this point
in his life liked to think of himself as
a rather isolated figure he was a cranky
guy he knew lots of people of course but
he liked to quarrel a lot he was rather
solitary in his habits
it was a great drinker and he I think
identified with Marx's Marx's sensible
eagerness he also identified with
another aspect of Marx which he's very
good at bringing out which is that Marx
was a great hater he in in political
infighting Marx was completely merciless
and he when he went after somebody and
wrote a critique of somebody's thought
it was cut them right down to the ground
and I think Wilson envied a little and
identified a little with that
characteristic of Marx's temperament so
let me read a passage about Marx this
just has to do with the Marx is a living
situation when he was exiled moved to
England which is where he wrote Das
Kapital
Marx when he first came to England had
taken furnished lodgings for his family
in a fashionable suburb of Canberra well
but they were evicted in the spring of
1854 inability to pay the rent had
resorted to a poor Street in Soho there
the whole family lived in two small dark
unventilated rooms there were six of
them with the children and with the maid
Helene DeMuth called luncheon Jenny's
mother that's Marx's wife had given her
as a wedding present and who though they
rarely had the money to pay her was to
stay with them to the end of their lives
the boy that Jenny had born a few days
after coming to England died in this
place
that November they had been turned out
while she was still nursing the baby
there's an X stand and apparently
voracious account of the Marx household
at this time when they were living in
Soho by police agent who got to see them
in 1853 now this is quoted from the
police agents report Marx lives in one
of the worst therefore one of the
cheapest neighborhoods in London he
occupies two rooms the room looking out
on the street is the parlor in the
bedroom is at the back there's not one
clean or decent piece of furniture in
either room but everything is broken
tattered and torn with thick dust over
everything and the greatest untied enos
everywhere in the middle of the parlor
there is a large old-fashioned table
covered with oil cloth on it there
manuscripts books and newspapers as well
as the children's toys odds and ends
from his wife's sewing basket cups with
broken rims dirty spoons knives and
forks lamps and ink pot tumblers some
Dutch clay pipes tobacco ashes all in a
pile on the same table when you go into
Marx's room smoke and tobacco fumes make
your eyes water to such an extent that
for the first moment you seem to be
groping about in a cavern until you get
used to it and managed to pick out
certain objects in the haze everything
is dirty and covered with dust and
sitting down is quite a dangerous
business here's a chair with only three
legs then another which happens to be
hole in which the children are playing
it cooking that is the one that is
offered to the visitor but the
children's cooking is not removed and if
you sit down you risk a pair of trousers
but all these things do not in the least
embarrass Marx or his wife you are
received in the most friendly way and
cordially offered pipes tobacco and
whatever else there may happen to be
eventually a clever and interesting
conversation arises which makes amends
for all the domestic difficulties so
that you find the discomfort bearable
you actually get used to the company and
find it interesting and original that's
end of that quote from the police report
this is Wilson sometimes they lived on
bread and potatoes for days once when
the Baker had given them notice and
asked for Marks when he brought the
bread a little boy then seven and a half
had saved the situation by answering no
he ain't upstairs grabbing the bread and
rushing off to deliver it to his father
they pawned everything at one time or
another including the children's shoes
and Marx's coat which prevented them
from going out of doors
Jenny's family silver went to the pond
piece by piece on one occasion the
pawnbroker seeing the crest of the duke
of argyll sent for the police and had
marks locked up was Saturday night his
respectable friends had all gone out of
town for the weekend so he had to stay
in jail till Monday morning sometimes
Jenny would cry all night and Carl would
lose his temper he was trying to write
his book on economics the neighborhood
was full of infections they survived a
cholera epidemic but one winter they all
had the grip at the same time my wife is
sick Jenny chin is sick mark marks wrote
two angles in 52 luncheon has a sort of
nervous fever I can and haven't been
able to call the doctor because I
haven't any money for medicine Mark's
was visited with piles and boils which
made it impossible for him to sit down
and prevented his frequenting the
library in March of 1851 another little
girl was born but she died of bronchitis
a year later she never had a cradle and
Jenny had gone to a French refugee to
borrow two pounds for a coffin in
January 1855 another girl was born but
in April the surviving boy died Lieb
nick said is one of the wilson sources
leave nick says that he had quote
magnificent eyes and a promising head
which was however much too heavy for his
body end quote and he had shown signs of
inheriting his father's brilliance it
was he when i witted the baker but he
was delicate and they had no way of
taking care of him
Mark's was more affected by the death of
this boy than by that of any of his
other children the house seems deserted
in empty he writes Engles since the
death of the child who was its living
soul it is impossible to describe how
much we constantly miss him I've
suffered all sorts of bad luck but now I
know for the first time what a genuine
misfortune is the police agent who had
been quoted above said that Mark's quote
as a husband and father in spite of his
wild and restless character was the
gentlest and mildest of men and quote
and everybody bears him out with his
family Carl Marx was a patriarch and
where he dominated he was able to love
he always turned off his cynical jokes
and his bad language when there were
women or children present if anybody
said anything off-color he would become
nervous and even blush he liked to play
games with his children and is said to
have written several of the biting pages
of the eighteenth Brumaire of Louis
Bonaparte while they were sitting behind
him
horse and whipping him to get he app
used to tell them a long-continued story
about an imaginary character named Hans
Racal who kept an enchanting toy shop
but who never had any money in his
pocket he had men and women dwarves and
Giants kings and queens masters and
journeyman
birds and four-footed beasts as many as
there were in Noah's Ark tables and
chairs boxes and carriages big and
little and all made out of wood but in
spite of the fact that he was a magician
he had debts to the butcher and the
devil which he was never able to pay and
so he was forced to his great distress
to sell all his beautiful things piece
by piece
to the devil and then finally I read a
little passage about Lenin interesting
thing just contextually about the
treatment of Lenin here is that Lenin of
course is paired with Trotsky very much
as angles and marks are paired in the
story and what's interesting is that
Wilson has very little interest in or
sympathy for Trotsky and it's odd
because in the late 1930s Trotsky was
much the champion of the left-leaning
intellectuals who were disaffected with
Stalinist communism and it's therefore
odd that though
Wilson treats Lenin very respectfully in
fact I think makes him a hero of the
book he's very derogatory towards
Trotsky and he ascribes in fact a
Trotsky a lot of the vices that he might
easily have described to Lenin or Stalin
in particular the high posterize ation
of history this idea that you really are
on the right side of the wrong side of
history and if you're on the wrong side
of history go to the dustbin you know
that's a phrase that Trotsky coined the
dustbin of history Wilson thinks all
that kind of talk is nonsense and he
makes good deal of fun of Trotsky but as
I say he's very attracted to Lenin and
I'm going to read a short passage of
description of Lenin when he first meets
Trotsky Lenin is in exile in London
Trotsky comes to meet him
Trotsky arrived there in the early dawn
in London it was October and he went
immediately to Lennon's lodgings on the
Tottenham Court Road where he and
krupskaya were masquerading krupskaya is
his Lennon's wife were masquerading as a
German couple named Richter and loudly
docked three times on the door as he'd
been instructed to do
krupskaya came down and let him in cairo
has arrived she announced Lenin was
still in bed and received him with
cordiality but surprise troops Gaia paid
off the cab men then went to make them
coffee when she when she came back she
found Vladimir Ilych sitting on the bed
and animated conversation with Trotsky
on some rather abstract theme Lenin took
him for a walk around London Trotsky
tells him an impression he received on
this occasion in a passage so remarkable
that it must be given direct in his own
words quote from a bridge
Lenin pointed out Westminster and some
other famous buildings I don't remember
the exact words he used but what he
conveyed was this is their famous
Westminster and they're referred of
course not to the English but to the
ruling classes this implication which
was not in the least emphasized but
coming as it did from the very innermost
depths of the man and expressed more by
the tone of his voice than by anything
else was always present whether Lenin
was speaking of the treasures of culture
of new achievements of the wealth of
books in the British Museum of the
information the larger European
newspapers or years later of German
artillery or French aviation they know
this or they have that they have made
this or achieve that but what enemies
they are to his eyes the invisible
shadow of the ruling classes always
overlay the whole of human culture a
shadow that was as real to him as
daylight end quote
this is Wilson for Lenin had succeeded
completely as Marx had not been able to
do in putting himself outside of the
owning classes quite clear and quite
frank as we have seen about his
equipment as a bourgeois intellectual
and his function as a director of the
working class he had now by his actual
mode of life identified himself with the
dispossessed it is been said and it is
not unlikely that he and krupskaya
refrained from having children because
they knew that with their meager
resources their constant shifting from
place to place the danger which which
they had always to reckon of landing in
exile or jail a family could only have
hampered them and following their prime
line of duty and Lenin cared so little
for luxuries that it was not difficult
as time went on he became more and more
dependent on a salary from the party
that was sometimes hardly enough to live
on for him to dispense with ordinary
comforts he had been in his early years
so indifferent to what he wore that his
mother and his sister Anna and made
periodical trips to st. Petersburg to
outfit him with new clothes
scoops kaya arrived in Munich she had
found him living in a small furnished
room and drinking tea out of a tin mug
which he washed every time he used it
and hung up on a nail by the tap in
attempting after Lenin's death to
destroy what she regarded as the legend
that their life had been full of
privations groups kaya only succeeds in
showing the unconscious austerity of
their standards they were never she says
in such straits as certain others of the
emigrate comrades who sometimes had no
means of earning a living for as long as
ten years received no money from Russia
and literally suffered from hunger but
in her memoirs she tells how they lived
in Munich first with a working-class
family of six who crowded into a small
kitchen and small room and kitchen while
they themselves had a single room then
in a small house in the suburbs was
furniture which they bought themselves
in which they sold when they left for
twelve marks when they had been forced
to move East credit journal but to
London by the imminence of the Tsarist
police that had first inhabited a dreary
bed sitting-room and later was crypt sky
as mother arrived the two rooms in which
Trotsky found them they did all their
work themselves and it also to cook for
the comrades who were always around the
apartment and often spent the night on
the floor their rooms were the
headquarters for escrow let him possess
no stock of books like Marx it did most
of his reading in libraries in so in
denying that Lenin was ascetic she only
throws into relief the relentless
concentration with which he pursued his
purpose vladimir Ilyich insists was
interested in all phases of life and
liked to amuse himself but these
amusements turn out to have consisted of
frequenting those theaters in Paris
where he could hear a singer the son of
a commune art who wrote revolutionary
songs in London of May
excursions to Primrose Hill because it
was near the grave of Marx and of bus
rides in the more respectable
thoroughfares supplemented by walks in
the working class districts Lenin would
mutter in English Disraeli x' phrase to
nation's my favorite line in the book is
the last line of the book the story as I
said ends with the arrival at Finland
station of Lenin and his wife he doesn't
know what to expect there he's travelled
in the steel train across Europe and
he's greeted as a hero of the revolution
he had almost expected that he would end
up in the theater and paul fortress as a
prisoner and he gives this great speech
everybody is rallying around him it's
this great moment when everything seems
to be happening for him and after the
speech is over and they go back from the
palace he and his wife go back to the
room of some relatives in st. Petersburg
where they're going to stay and when
they get to the room they see that one
of the children the family had hung up
over their beds the last words of the
Communist Manifesto workers of the world
unite
krupskaya says she hardly spoke to
Ilyich everything was understood without
words thank you so I'd be happy to talk
some more about the book or Wilson
before we start I wanted to ask you to
please use the audience mic
we will not entertain questions of
people who stand up at their seats it's
much better to hear with the audience
mic we can have interchange and but
before you start to answer questions
maybe you would tell us how we're
supposed to read this book now uhm
slowly
yeah because it's a great pleasure to
read it I think that the it's it's I
still find it's fairly easy to discount
for the problems with the book that I
began by talking about in the beginnings
that we were talking to that what you're
thinking of politics on it yeah
through the century that communism a so
effective and and we've come out the
other end of it and seen how it didn't
answer the problems that it purported to
answer um here's how I read it and this
is just may not want to try this at home
but the story to me still has great
poignancy it also has a message the
what's moving about the book the
poignant part of it is the dream that
these writers and thinkers have in the
19th century about a better world
don't forget the conditions of
industrial capitalism in Europe much
different from what the conditions of
capitalism in our lifetimes and the
misery the immiseration was visible was
palpable it was enormous and very few
people had any ideas about how to
overcome that make life better for the
mass of people and so it is very
poignant to watch these people
struggling to come up with a diagnosis
of the situation and a plan for
revolutionary action and the that kind
of thought is very is very powerfully
evoked by Wilson WH Auden once said that
a man who was struggling to save himself
from drowning is an intellectual because
he is thinking about his condition and
something like that is true of the these
people in Wilson's book they all
suffered I mean I read these passages to
show you that they all suffered in their
own lives and they suffered too because
for almost all of them until Lennon's
time everything they did ended in
failure they were ignore
they were vilified they were exiled they
died in poverty and yet they remained
true to this to the stream that they had
that's a wonderful thing and it's a
scary thing and the scary part is what
happened to it is that it got taken over
into a program for action and it became
a rigid authoritarian doctrine which
justified all kinds of violence cruelty
and killing but that can happen to any
idea it could happen to any idea it
doesn't mean that the idea is bad it
means that bad use is made of it it's
turned into a god and it's worshipped by
people it can happen to the idea of
liberal democracy can lead people to
think they have a mission in the world
to and they're going to know matter what
their that's the mission that history
has given them to perform
that's a scary way to conduct oneself so
that's just the way I read it the mic is
here yeah I think you might have you
just saw this one alluded to what the
question I was going to ask but it's my
understanding that it marks his writings
he did not advocate violence and so I'm
wondering I'm thinking of the term
Marxist Marxist Leninist
I think it was Lenin who advocated
violent as you said a man of action so
my question is what is is it more than
that what is Marx's Leninism is that
what you're just speaking about is it a
complete distortion of Marxism yeah well
Marx and Engels thought that that
history was going to unfold in a
particular way and they predicted the
Communist future based on their method
which they called not dialectical
materialism but historical materialism
so they were writers of history and
Wilson sense because they were trying to
make sense out of history to find the
meaning of history and they did so by
postulating this series of dialectical
movements within history in which
class replaces another class so they
concluded from that that the capitalist
system was one stage in this dialectical
process what Hegel would say history
realizing its idea and they postulated
that that would be replaced by a
dictatorship of the proletariat
ultimately classless society violence
isn't necessary if history is doing your
work for you in that sense you know but
violence is necessary because history
doesn't do his work for you as which is
what Lenin realized but also what extent
was Lenin committed to the principles of
Marxism or socialism and to what extent
was he interested in power I mean it's
very hard to answer those questions it's
part of the mystery of totalitarianism
is really where it comes from obviously
comes from ideas but it involves some
element of personality and some
distortion that's unpredictable really
so yeah Marxist Leninist M is a is a is
a is a foreign policy Marxism is a
theory of history I was I recently read
homage to Catalonia which was published
in September late late in 1937 just as
Wilson was writing this book was Wilson
familiar with Orwell's work and was he
influenced by him yeah I missed
Catalonia of course is Georgia all
worlds account of his experiences during
the Spanish Civil War Orwell was a
revolutionary socialist he actually did
believe in violence if it was necessary
in order to bring socialism to England
he brought about it several different
places and when he went to Spain he
fought of course for the loyalists and
he fought with etruscan brigade and he
witnessed the suppression of the
trotskyist by the Stalinist in among the
loyalist forces and homage to Catalonia
is his account of that it was a great
expose at the time because it showed
people that the Communist Party
Stalin's Communist Party was not to be
trusted
that it was vicious and violent and
really turned or well into his
anti-stalinist phase which you know we
know from animal
later 1984 Wilson certainly knew
Orwell's book he also knew other books
that have been written about the Soviet
Union which were quite critical of it by
former admirers and rag'd had written a
book called visit I think visitor to the
USSR John Dos Passos it was a very good
friend of Wilson's had also been to
Russia and written a book attacking
Stalinist Russia Dos Passos had been a
very much a left winger and back in the
1920s so he was very aware that a big
revision was going on don't forget also
that Wilson was very close to a lot of
the New York intellectuals who were at
partisan review in 1937 I believe was
also the year that partisan review
became an anti-communist
Marxist Journal it partisan view had
been part of the Jon REEP Club and the
Communist Party and they broke away from
that Phillips and Robb so he was when he
was finishing his book when he was
writing the Lenin parts he was very much
in contact with people who were in
process of repudiating their allegiances
to two Soviet Communism so as I say it's
an interesting it's interesting that
Wilson chose to stay with his plan with
the book and it's de nada T of the book
in a way because he knew by the time he
finished she knew perfectly well what we
know now yes sir I have a sort of
stylistic question in the metaphysical
Club you follow
I think pragmatism as an idea all the
way through and it visits different
thinkers as it evolves and you mentioned
that you were influenced by Wilson's
book where he took socialism as a
vehicle if you if you know if historians
pull a Boswell you know where they do a
literary approach to history it pounded
on have you got pounded on for being
artistic interpreting history by the
kanata got a canonical conservative
historian I feel I should have been but
no the to my great pleasure and
gratitude that historians have been very
favorable and their the reviews I've
read of the book by professional
historians they're they seem seem
pleased with it I think there's some
philosophers who you know have quibbles
about it but but that's because they
don't particularly like pragmatism but
no I found it I found it it was
okay I didn't I'm not a historian I'm an
English professor and I certainly didn't
write the book as a scholarly
intervention and historical professional
historical debate or anything of that
kind I just I wanted to bring a story to
life I wanted to do what I felt Wilson
was able to do and I therefore I told it
as a story because that seemed to me the
best way to bring that about so I I am
very gratified that so historians I I
know or in the periods seem happy with
the way I wrote the book
one last question is Lenin equivalent to
Holmes well yeah in a way I end my book
with Holmes who also start my book with
Oliver Wendell Holmes and he sort of the
climax of the book yeah there's a little
bit of a a little bit of Lennon in
Oliver Wendell Holmes that's a good
question yes sir I was intrigued with
your discussion a moment ago about the
they their understanding and use of
history and there's another kind of
movement or strain that comes originated
around the same time and that's
Christian fundamentalism and it begins
with a Church of England priest John
Nelson Darby who is unhappy with the
established Church and he goes and he
begins to look at the Bible as history
and we have and it has had enormous
influence and I wonder what it is
about the times that produce all these
people trying to use history trying and
an equally following following some idea
some imagined and imagined golden
futurism sir what time this is in the
30s 1820s Oh 1818 twice from some of the
men who were in the wilderness that the
precursors that Marx's precursor I would
put it this way I think that it has to
do with the society becoming modern
because in pre-modern society
ladies life is conceived of as cyclical
this is that people reproduce the
customs and habits of the previous
generation and they pass those on to the
next generation it's not as though
society isn't expected to change people
are expected to fulfill the role that
they're given at birth in a society and
if they fulfilled that role honorably
then their death is meaningful because
they've passed on that role to the next
generation one of the characteristics of
modern society is that we don't think
that way we don't think our society
should always be the same we think we
should be innovative and creative we
also don't think that people should
fulfill the roles that they're given at
Birth we think that they should be
creative with their own life histories
and do something that's different from
what their parents did we expect that to
happen the whole economy is predicated
on that happening as well as where we
educate people so there's something a
little anomic about that kind of life
and we probably wouldn't give it up for
the other kind for a pre-modern life but
in a pre-modern life all kinds of
existential problems don't arise because
there's it's given to you out there what
how to have a meaningful life it's not
so clear in our society what a
meaningful life would be I think one of
the arbiters therefore of meaning in
life becomes history in the 19th century
because it's a way of saying I can make
sense of my life by looking at its place
in a larger drama which is the drama of
historical change now historical changes
is higgledy-piggledy if historical
changes just as Henry Ford said or
somebody said one damn thing after
another was Henry Ford he said history
is blog anyway if it's just if it's
higgledy-piggledy then to identify
yourself with history is it doesn't
solve any problems for you because
history is just as random and arbitrary
is everyday life seems to be but you can
you can get over the anomic feeling that
your everyday life doesn't have shape or
purpose by identifying yourself with a
larger historical narrative and
historical arc and that's what these
guys into the Finland station all do
they they rationalize their suffering by
believing that their part
a larger movement which is the movement
of history and they understand a
movement by studying life historically
because if they can figure out the law
of historical development then they can
understand what their place is and then
their life is given some kind of meaning
I think we still do that to a degree I
think we still try to identify ourselves
to a degree with the zeitgeist or with a
sense of you know there's a there's a
that there's actually some kind of
trajectory out there that were part of
but certainly in the 19th century people
elevated that belief into a kind of
religion and Marx was its great prophet
and so in the 1930s when in the Western
economies it seemed as though everything
was collapsing and there was no order or
sense of direction and the old order
seemed unrevised liberal order people
did again turn to history and turn to
Marx as the great prophet of historical
transformation sir thank you very much
for your most erudite presentations a
few questions about Wilson himself as he
got into the 1960s what were his
political sympathies if any a and my
recollection is that he was at Princeton
had he now become an academic and was he
teaching and lastly what got him into
the American Civil War because I always
felt that patriotic gore was one of the
most Magisterial works out I've ever
read and that's a quite a seemingly a
sea change from studying Marx and yeah
and that yeah um I Wilson not attended
Princeton where he was a friend of F
scott Fitzgerald who was he was friends
with for all Fitzgerald's life but he
did not ever teach at Princeton as far
as I know he only taught once he taught
for one year at the University of
Chicago he taught a class on Dickens
which was the basis for I think one of
the great Dickens essays called Dickens
the two Scrooge's which is in his
collection called the wound in the bow
and he had a terrible time students
hated him and he hated them and it
didn't work out he didn't have the
didn't have the patience to to be a
teacher so he so he was not a teacher
um his politics were
or he renounced a Stalinism in the
Soviet Union
earlier the 1950s I think you know
essentially before that but really by
the 50s he was clearly an anti-communist
one of the things interesting about him
though is he never went all the way to
the right the way a lot of former
Trotskyists and and communists or fellow
travelers did he didn't become a very
linea communist in fact he was very
opposed to the Cold War and in 1965 he
published a very strange book called the
Cold War in the income-tax Wilson had
somehow neglected to pay his income tax
for many years not that it was not that
it would have been very large because he
made very little money actually it's
rather surprising how little he made cuz
was quite well known by this point and
so he wrote a book claiming ex post
facto that disagreement with American
foreign policy was the reason why he
wasn't paying his income tax and it's a
very cranky and strange book but he but
he was he was not a he wasn't he did not
turn to the right and he did not become
what we think of as kind of a
neoconservative in his political views
at all I think he was still rather
progressive in his thought on the other
hand pretty much withdrew from
engagement with both political life and
also with contemporary literary life
remember that I mentioned Axel's castle
in 1931 that was a book about Bruce
Joyce Gertrude Stein writers who TS
Eliot writers who were then just coming
on to the scene or just you know very
current and Wilson was very brilliant in
understanding their work being able to
interpret it place it in a larger
context so he felt very much in the 20s
and 30s that he was part of literary
culture and it was an actor in it he
would also wrote novels short stories
poetry and also as a critic but after
1950 he really was drew from all of that
he he published there's a famous little
card that he had printed up for himself
and when he was writing for The New
Yorker he was book review for The New
Yorker reviewer for The New Yorker for
quite a while in the 50s and he had a
car printed up and said very long as the
things ought not what not all of which I
can remember but I said Edmund Wilson
will not
: right introductions attend conferences
go to symposia be on panels read
unsolicited manuscripts 400 different
thing so he really just didn't want to
deal with the public world I think that
therefore patriotic gore which was
published in 1962 which is really his
other kind of really big historical work
was a way to lose himself in the past he
was fascinated with the American past
he's the father of the library of
America that was his idea
those Library of America volumes was
something he dreamed up and and Jason
Epstein who had published him at anchor
is the guy who made it happen
Wilson called them the American play
yard he's very interested in American
history in the American past and and
patriotic Gore was just the kind of
thing to absorb him in all of that he
said most of his time living in on Cape
Cod is the typical perversity only lived
there in the winter whenever he had to
go to the beach he would wear a white
dress shirt everybody would make fun of
him he said oh we know one way how to
dress and then he was been the summer
Talcott fill upstate New York is this a
house that had belonged to his family
there and he would just sit with a
bottle of scotch and write and these
fantastic books patriotic or Dead Sea
Scrolls and so forth and so he kind of
withdrew I think in the end he kind of
liked the idea of being a bit of an
outsider okay thank you very much
thank Thank You Lois Manan it's always a
pleasure for more information on to the
finland station visit the New York
Review of Books website NY books.com
slash n yr b
[Music]